[Música]
estão com a sensação de que está cada
vez mais difícil dialogar com as pessoas
como está sendo nos últimos tempos a
discussão sobre temas sociais na sua
vida
por muito tempo eu achava que a chave
para que a gente tivesse melhores
discussões e conseguisse discutir os
nossos problemas sociais era que a gente
tivesse mais empatia e mais respeito que
afinal se nós todos somos seres humanos
somos iguais nesse sentido se a gente
compartilha das mesmas necessidades como
é que a gente não consegue se entender
demorou um tempo para entender que essa
equação da empatia não era algo tão
simples assim e eu lembro direitinho do
dia e essa complexidade começou a
aparecer mais claramente pra mim eu
assistir um vídeo junto do youtube desse
cara o príncipe ea ele é o youtube negro
famoso americano que fez desse vídeo
chamado eu não sou negro você não é
branco
nesse vídeo ele falava que nós somos
muito mais do que a nossa cor da pele
que a cor da pele é um rótulo e que a
gente devia se relacionar para além dele
na época eu achei que esse vídeo tinha
tudo a ver com a comunicação não
violenta que eu estava começando a
aprender ea praticar e aí eu fui lá o
compartilhar em um grupo do facebook de
praticantes de comunicação não violenta
e para minha surpresa depois de poucos
minutos eu recebi esse comentário de uma
mulher negra que tinha assistido vídeo e
ela dizia
na verdade esse vídeo é superficial ao
tratar origens étnicas como rótulos raça
humana é utilizada hoje para silenciar o
diferente como saber quem eu sou se me
pedem a diluição da identidade
eu entendi a proposta do vídeo mas não
acredito que contemple o que vivemos
hoje porque
está social é outra e eu confesso que na
hora que eu li o comentário eu tive um
bug assim eu falei com nelsinho o vídeo
falando que a gente tem que se tratar
com respeito de igual pra igual e o que
ela tava me ensinando ali naquele
momento era justamente que quando a
gente tenta se tratar de igual para
igual
em uma sociedade na qual a gente é
diferente que isso era uma maneira de
ser violenta
então naquele momento aquela mulher
estava ensinando uma lição que depois eu
fui entender que era mesmo uma grande
lição que o próprio márcio rosenberg
criador da comunicação não violenta e
deixou de legado e que muitas pessoas
inclusive que tanto dano comunicação não
violenta
muitas vezes não sabem o passa
despercebido
o que eu acho dizia é que se eu uso a
comunicação não violenta
só para pacificar as relações de família
e de amigos pra gente se comunicar
bonitinho melhor do melhor conexão é
votar usando a cnv como narcótico a cnv
não nasceu só pra isso
ela nasceu também para transformar
positivamente os sistemas sociais bem
a partir disso eu comecei a pesquisar um
pouco mais do cenário social que a gente
vive
eles sabiam que o país é o nono país que
o brasil é o nono país mais desigual do
mundo
nós somos a oitava economia nós somos o
nono país mais igual e quando a gente
nasce em um país e uma sociedade que é
desigual
o nosso nascimento se torna uma
verdadeira loteria porque porque
dependendo da família do lugar onde você
nasce já tenho coisas que estão sendo
pré determinadas na sua vida nas em uma
família que tem dinheiro é o maior
privilégio que existe por que por que em
uma sociedade capitalista dinheiro é
igual a oportunidade e aí quando eu
começo a falar esse tipo de coisa
rapidinho eu já escuto ele não falando
assim em carol como assim a filha as
pessoas têm que fazer por merecer né que
as pessoas tem que batalhar por elas
mesmas
eu conheço pessoas que saíram da miséria
e hoje conquistaria uma vida confortável
aqui mesmo nesse evento
a gente viu algumas pessoas certas
só que gente e talvez então vocês alguém
que esteja assistindo agora seja uma
dessas pessoas
só que isso ainda é uma história de
exceção não é uma história que considera
o cenário social no qual a gente vive
o brasil é o país que tem o menor índice
de mobilidade social do mundo então é
possível ascender socialmente aqui claro
que é possível eu sei disso eu também
conheço pessoas que têm histórias desse
tipo só que é o lugar mais difícil do
mundo pra que esse tipo de história
possa acontecer né e aí conforme eu fui
pesquisando eu fui percebendo que essa
questão da desigualdade social ela está
intimamente relacionada com a questão
étnico-racial então no brasil a
população a população mais pobre
os 10% mais pobres do brasil são
maioritariamente compostos por pessoas
negras então 78% dessa população mais
pobre é de das pessoas negras
isso é a gente está falando de
patrimônio mas quando a gente vai
analisar também a renda a renda das
pessoas negras é em média 1.200 reais a
menos do que as pessoas brancas no
brasil
e aí você for ver os dados de homicídio
que o pai é o brasil também é um dos
países que mais têm homicídio no mundo
se você for ver quem são as pessoas que
mais morrem esses homicídios também a
maioria de pessoas negras 75% e
principalmente de jovens negros
então não seria um exagero dizer que os
brancos vivem
o brasil e os negros vivem em outro
brasil e isso tem tudo a ver com
privilégios né quando eu falo essa
palavra privilégio
eu já escuto eu já escutei várias vezes
as pessoas falando assim o é mas como
assim
privilégio né então uma pessoa branca
pode escutar todos esses dados sobre
desigualdade racial e pensar mas eu não
sou privilegiado
o homem pode escutar vários dados sobre
o feminicídio sobre desigualdade
salarial sobre estupro contra a mulher e
pensar mas eu não sou um privilegiado
porque quando a gente passa falar essa
palavra privilegiado
parece que eu tô falando assim a sua
privilegiada e não só a vida é fácil né
como assim a minha vida é fácil não é
porque eu sou privilegiado que eu tenho
uma vida fácil e não é mesmo
então é bom ficar na mesma página do que
significa privilégio privilégio por
definição é uma condição de vantagem
atribuída a uma pessoa ou grupo em
comparação aos demais então privilégio
não tem absolutamente nada a ver com
algo que você faça ou deixe de fazer uma
canção foi dada na sua vida
então por exemplo se você nasceu em uma
família que sempre estimulou a estudar
falou que o estudo era algo pra você que
nunca preciso falar assim o meu filho
minha filha vai lá trabalhar porque você
precisa contribuir com a renda da
família
isso é um privilégio se o seu tataravô
usou sua bisavó direta não foram pessoas
escravizadas
isso é um privilégio se você na rua sem
medo de ser estuprado
isso é um privilégio então não é nada
que você fez ou deixou de fazer que
contribuiu para a construção desse
cenário isso tudo são características
que foram atribuídas
e a partir do momento que eu comecei a
pesquisar mais nem entender melhor esse
cenário e ver que esse cenário foi
construído muito por conta da história
do brasil né então fazem somente 133
anos que aconteceu que as pessoas
escravizadas conquistaram a liberdade e
elas não tiveram nenhum tipo de subsídio
para recomeçarem a vida delas depois
disso pelo contrário elas tiveram muitos
dos direitos delas ainda não não
reconhecidos e isso tudo que eu tô
falando a gente é ele é um pequeno
recorte da desigualdade brasileira
porque a gente pode acrescentar mais
camadas por exemplo se a gente
condiciona a esse debate a questão de
gênero a gente começa a entender dados
alarmantes por exemplo da vida da mulher
negra no brasil que é o indivíduo que
está sofrendo dupla pressão e eu comecei
a perceber que tem várias coisas que nós
privilegiados fazemos quando nós somos
questionados dos nossos privilégios né
eu comecei a entender que empatia não
era só uma questão de ser respeitoso com
quem estava na minha frente
empatia passava por reconhecer os
próprios privilégios primeiro entender
como funcionam essas opressões
estruturais e começará a direcionar o
meu trabalho ea minha energia para
contribuir para a diminuição dessas
desigualdades e quando eu comecei a ver
as reações que a gente tinha eu pensei
poxa eu quero começar a falar isso pros
mais para mais pessoas para que a gente
possa rever a nossa atitude e quem sabe
contribuir da melhor forma para esse
cenário
então vocês aqui já devem ter sido
acusado de alguma vez de machista ou
alguém falou essa sua atitude foi
homofóbica
alguém falou em sua fala foi racista
você já deve ter passado por uma
situação assim como é que foi
você reagiu será que você teve alguma
dessas reações aqui ó
será que você disse assim meu mas nós
somos todos humanos
essa luta das minorias só serve para nos
dividir
ou será que falou assim olha a questão
esse negócio de racismo de machismo isso
tudo é mimi porque a questão mesmo é a
pobreza
ou então você falou a clássica né
imagina eu não sou homofóbico que até um
amigo que é gay ou então você ficou
chateado é porque fez uma piada o
pessoal no rio e falou pô
hoje em dia as pessoas opina contudo não
dá pra brincar com nada
ou ainda isso daqui é um falso pedido de
desculpas você disse
me desculpa se você ficou atendido
porque achou que eu sou machista ou
ainda você pode ter ficado tão chateado
de receber esse feedback que você chorou
ou de alguma maneira você redirecionou
toda a atenção daquela discussão pra
você
gente quando a gente faz qualquer uma
dessas atitudes na verdade o que a gente
está demonstrando é que a gente não
entendeu que o problema é estrutural
a gente ainda está baseando a nossa
visão de mundo a partir da nossa própria
experiência do que a gente vê desse meu
amigo gay dessa pessoa que eu sei que
conquistou o lugar é isso não tá olhando
para o cenário amplo não tá entendendo
que é sistêmico ou pior ainda a gente tá
caindo no lugar de culpa por ser
privilegiado
então eu não quero ser vista como uma
pessoa racista e aí a pessoa fala que eu
sou racista eu choro porque eu quero me
vulnerabilizar para ela ver o quanto eu
realmente me importo
e eu que estou fazendo contínuo
protagonizando a cena eu nunca saiu de
cena eu nunca do espaço para outras
pessoas entrarem na cena então sentir
culpa por seus privilégios
não vai ajudar em nada seus privilégios
não tem a ver com algo que você fez ou
deixou de fazer então mais importante do
que sentir culpa é ser responsável por
fazer alguma coisa com eles mas então na
diante de tudo isso
isso aqui foi o que a gente faz e que na
verdade bloqueia conexão mas o que é que
a gente pode fazer
a primeira coisa é entender a diferença
entre intenção impacto
então imagina que eu estou na praia
jogando frescobol com o amigo aí de
repente eu quero dar um saque mais
ousado assim ele sai todo torto e vai
direto e pega no seu nariz quando ele
começa a sangrar
aí fica indignado e vem na minha direção
e fala pô
olha aqui porque aconteceu e aí eu diria
que eu vim pra você e falha assim mas
também nessa etapa aqui na praia tem um
bom time jogando frescobol podia
acontecer com qualquer um
e aí fala assim o que ela está sangrando
você não vai pedir desculpas e eu vim
pra vocês assim olha não era minha
intenção de machucar tá eu não sou uma
pessoa agressiva eu nunca machucaria
nariz de alguém estranho eu continuar me
justificando que é continuar me
defendendo e isso é uma situação tão
tribo é trivial quanto ficar jogando
frescobol na praia machucar alguém
agora imagina quando a gente está
falando de opressões estruturais que são
temas verdadeiramente doloridos
para quem sofre a opressão então nós
pessoas privilegiadas a gente tem que
abrir o nosso ouvido para o real impacto
das nossas acções e reconhecer que as
nossas ações nossas falas podem ter um
impacto de machucar os outros e
realmente tentar não repetir aquele tipo
de ofensa
agora como eu disse a questão não é só
individual ela é estrutural
então uma parte da discussão precisa ir
para o campo político e que a gente pode
fazer nesse sentido
tem muita gente que acha que
quando políticas públicas são criadas
como por exemplo cotas para negros nas
universidades ou cotas para as mulheres
nas políticas na política
tem pessoas que falam ah mas isso é dar
privilégio pra esse grupo não é
privilégio gente é reparação histórica
porque os o problema estrutural é
preciso ter ações afirmativas para mudar
esse cenário e é claro que esse tipo de
política é passível de crítica seria
muito melhor se o sistema de base
brasileiro fosse tivesse uma educação
incrível ea gente não precisasse criar
cotas na universidade
só que vocês sabem que desde os fins
desde o início do sistema de cotas em
2000 o número de matrículas de pessoas
negras nas universidades públicas
brasileiras era de apenas 11% em 2017 já
era de 30%
é claro que a gente tem um longo caminho
pela frente mas pelo menos isso já é um
avanço
outra coisa que a gente pode fazer
também é provocar os ambientes que a
gente ocupa porque em maior ou menor
grau todos nós temos algum tipo de
privilégio
então se você é líder dentro de uma
organização se pode questionar a
pluralidade da sua equipe
se você matrícula o seu filho uma boa
escola
você tem a oportunidade de questionar
diretoria daquela escola sobre a
diversidade do corpo docente dos alunos
que vão frequentar aquela escola
se você é homem você tem abertura para
quando os seus amigos estiverem fazendo
alguma piadinha no grupo d o desapego e
fomenta a cultura de estupro de dar um
toque pra eles de que se não é legal que
já está na hora de mudar
então tem muita gente que acha que a
empatia é você respeitar a opinião do
outro independente de qual seja essa
opinião
eu vejo que tem muita gente que espera
de mim isso é uma facilitadora de
comunicação não violenta que eu seja
neutra mas a partir do momento que eu
consegui comecei a ver esses dados de
desigualdade
eu percebi que a minha neutra
idade poderia ser só mais uma maneira de
perpetuar essa desigualdade e portanto a
violência então como uma mãe que quer o
melhor para o filho é não vou falar que
está tudo bem a gente continuar tendo
opiniões que aumentam esse nosso abismo
social como dia-a-dia mila ribeiro
empatia não é um saber me colocar no
lugar do outro porque eu nunca vou saber
como está no lugar do outro
empatia é eu saber como meu lugar
impacto lugar do outro assim como a
diana ribeiro existem centenas de
pesquisadores intelectuais filósofos
negros que já estão falando isso há
muito tempo então nada do que estou
falando aqui é novidade
inclusive essa foi uma das coisas que eu
fiz que me ajudou muito
ampliar as minhas referências quem são
as pessoas que eu escuto quem são as
pessoas quem o que eu leio quem são as
pessoas que eu admiro será que todas
elas são iguais a mim
a partir do momento que eu comecei
ampliar essa essas minhas referências eu
percebi que o meu mundo se abriu
então gente hoje eu acredito que não tem
como falar em empatia e respeito sem
falar em consciência social
esse evento é um evento que está falando
muito de futuro de tecnologia quando é
que a gente vai começar a pensar em
tecnologias de convivência
quando a gente vai começar a pensar em
uma sociedade verdadeiramente o mais
igualitária pra todo mundo
então se você que é ajudar a construir
uma sociedade mais simpática eu preciso
te perguntar o que é que você vai fazer
com seus privilégios
obrigada
[Aplausos]